tonight we have to start with something
you're rarely ever gonna see on this
program we need to thank the mainstream
media mop in their latest rage-filled
psychotic effort to smear President
Trump they accidentally did his campaign
and frankly the country a huge favor in
fact the media unintentionally stumbled
onto what our serious credible claims of
corruption surrounding one of the
president's potential 2020 opponents
that would be sleepy creepy crazy Uncle
Joe 303 304 comprehensive coverage we're
gonna go chapter and verse very slowly
you will understand it gets a little
complicated but we've got the timeline
down perfectly the story they won't tell
you in the media the real corrupt
dealings the abuse of power by Joe Biden
a member of his family how they became
oh incredibly wealthy during his time in
the Obama administration cashing in on
his name in context contacts and we're
going to also lay it out step by step so
maybe even the media mob they pay close
enough attention maybe they'll learn
something for once that would all
started last week reports surfaced about
this unnamed whistleblower who is
accusing President Trump of making an
elicit unknown promise to Ukraine's
president during a recent phone call
Media jumps rushed to judgment again
breathlessly claiming the president
Trump well he wanted Ukraine to dig up
dirt on Joe Biden and for days we
witnessed a now predictable
obsessive-compulsive level of hysteria
they're breathless reporting we have
seen this now for over three years and
now that the Russia Russia Russia
impeachment impeachment impeachment
collusion collusion failed well they're
now accusing president Trump of
colluding with Ukraine and we know from
John Solomon Ukraine admits to trying to
influence the 2016 election to help
Hillary Clinton but the media mob they
only care about any foreign interference
in our elections if they can use it to
bludgeon Trump they cared about Russia
and Russia and appearance but not the
bought and paid for dossier many in the
media mob predicting this would be the
end of the Trump administration they've
been predicting that for three years and
as it turns out the so-called whistled
wasn't even actually on the call in
question whoops this was not the first
hand the information we were told by a
real whistleblower in other words this
was hearsay the whole every allegation
look at this even fake News CNN buried
in a report they did over the weekend
the following line the whistleblower
didn't have direct knowledge of the
communications that's called hearsay
that means the who knows what this
person heard it meanwhile the Ukrainian
foreign minister president denied
President Trump put pressure on the
Ukrainian president denied it flat-out
wrong and no quid pro quo and according
to the Washington Post yep no explicit
quid pro quo offered none zero he with
the very latest our own Catherine
Herridge in Washington tonight Catherine
person familiar with the situation tells
Fox News that the whistleblower did not
have quote first-hand knowledge of the
conversation between President Trump and
the Ukrainian president adding the
complaint makes clear the whistleblower
did not have direct knowledge of that
July phone call that matters because
typically multiple US officials are on
these calls with the president
indicating the whistleblower was not one
of them it's unclear how the individual
obtained a transcript heard about the
call or learned about it another way
after consulting with the Justice
Department the top lawyer for the Acting
Director of National Intelligence Joe
McGuire said the complaint was not
standard did not meet the statutory
definition of urgent and congressional
notification was not required today
speaking to reporters at the UN and
President Trump went on the offensive
did you tell the Ukrainian leader that
they would have the aid only if they
investigated Joe Biden and his family no
I did no I didn't I didn't
but Joe Biden said it about his son Joe
Biden was very dishonest what he did on
the whistleblower Lackey direct
knowledge of the call a separate source
told Fox News that weakens the complaint
but does not necessarily undercut all
allegations Democrats want McGuire's
testimony on Thursday Sean all right
Catherine in Washington tonight now we
will be joined by the great one Mark
Levin New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
former mayor also trey gowdy vice
president pence all weighing in tonight
along with John Solomon and Peter
Schweitzer they have written and have
investigated this extensively so it's
pretty clear the media's four day anti
Trump binge was yet another false
totally misguided and as usual they got
it all wrong moment
but despite so much terrible reporting
and propaganda and lies and misplaced
hysteria well we got a big thanks to the
media mob they've highlighted Joe Biden
and the country of Ukraine Biden's
conduct as vice president is now rightly
in the spotlight and as congressman
Devin Nunez put it this weekend well
this may be the end of Joe Biden's
campaign let's take a look the left
knows that Biden's son is a problem for
him this is why when Hillary Clinton was
running these stories first originated
first originated back when Hillary
Clinton was trying to make sure that
Biden didn't get in the race now that
these have been resurrected I don't know
who came up with a scheme maybe they're
really this whistleblower is not a
partisan I mean we want it we want to
hear from that whistleblower but it sure
looks like the scheme is backfired and
this I like I said I think this is
probably the end of my end of his
campaign hire I really do and the
congressman is Right Joe Biden and his
family should be very nervous tonight
and every American including President
Trump they should we should be demanding
answers all right now let's play cope
very close attention here because here
is what we know now thanks to the
investigative work of reporter John
Solomon along with Peter Schweitzer will
both join us in a moment we can lay out
a very damning timeline we start in 2014
this is when President Obama appointed
his Vice President Biden to lead the
administration's efforts in Ukraine
few months later April 2014 Biden's son
hunter he scored a lucrative position on
a board of a massive Ukrainian gas
company called Maurice Mahal dings
hunter Biden according to numerous
reports had zero experience in the
energy industry zero experience in the
oil and gas sector zero experience in
the country of Ukraine but this giant
Ukrainian oil and gas company reportedly
shelled out oh one hundred and sixty
some odd thousand a month more than
three million dollars total to Biden's
private equity firm during this time a
year later in November 2015 Joe Biden
was advised get this by the New York
Times that his son was under
investigation by Ukraine authorities oh
and in december of 2015 joe biden made
his first request to the president of
ukraine to fire the prosecutor leading a
corruption investigation into the
company the oil company parisa holdings
that his son hunter was doing business
with and making his son kind of really
wealthy filthy rich looks like the
classic pay to play scheme to me and in
March of 2016 according to the
investigative reporting of Salomon Vice
President President Biden he knew this
prosecutor was investigating his son and
was about to conduct an interview and
request that hunter Biden answer
questions about what it was he was doing
with this company that he was
investigating so what did then Vice
President Biden do he actually leveraged
1 billion dollars your tax dollars
US aid a billion dollars taxpayer
dollars and forced the Ukrainian
president at the time to fire this
prosecutor now we know this happen
because Biden well he couldn't help but
brag about it on camera we've got the
tape we're not going to give you the
million dollars they said you got no
authority you're not the president the
president said I said call
I think it was six hours I looked I said
we've in six hours if the prosecutor is
not fired you're not getting the money
prosecutor not fired you're not getting
the money now why would a vice-president
of the United States of America demand
that a Ukrainian prosecutor be fired and
leverage our tax dollars to insist on
the firing hmm that's a little odd don't
you think now it is US law that all
federal officials avoid even the
appearance of a conflict of interest
when they are conducting u.s. foreign
policy and clearly this was of no
concern to Sleepy creepy crazy sleazy
Uncle Joe 303 302 the entire media mob
either we know where they stand on these
things they're now doing their very best
to cover for the ailing 2020 contender
that is now in second place in the
latest Iowa poll in fact after running
wild with the Russia collusion hoax two
and a half plus years lies
misinformation propaganda conspiracy
theories and a hoax they haven't learned
a thing because the media mob is now
telling you that any accusation of
Biden's wrongdoing is a conspiracy
theory no that would be a lie take a
look what actually happened with the
Biden's in Ukraine will fact check the
conspiracy theory Trump is making a
wholly unsubstantiated claim when he
alleges corruption by the Biden's there
is no evidence of any wrongdoing
president Trump has repeatedly suggested
without evidence that Joe Biden used his
VP position to pressure Ukraine to fire
the country's top prosecutor there's no
proof whatsoever that Joe Biden did
anything wrong or that Hunter Biden did
anything wrong does it look great it
doesn't look great
but but there's no evidence there these
things just kind of were both occurring
this could end up being like the 20/20
version of birtherism Oh Joe Biden did
something bad in Ukraine actually the
proof is in Biden's own words and the
proof is the Sun we can't find any
evidence that he knew anything about oil
gas energy or Ukraine well then why did
they pay him millions of dollars I guess
they didn't see the tape Abidin bragging
about getting the Ukrainian prosecutor
fired by leveraging our tax dollars and
by the way where I grew up that kind of
sounds like either you do what I say
kind of sounds like a blackmail sort of
thing but that's where I grew up I won't
use that phrase and maybe they just
don't care because it doesn't fit their
psychotic rage Trump hating narrative
now this weekend our very own Peter
Doocy
he asked Biden had an opportunity to ask
him a question about this conflict of
interest in Ukraine and there was one
angry Uncle Joe 303 309 let's take a
look mr. vice president
how many times have you ever spoken to
your son about his overseas business
dealings I've never spoken about his
overseas resumes you should be looking
at Trump Trump's doing this because
knows I'll beat him like a drum and is
using the abuse of power and every
element of the presidency to try to do
something to smear me everybody looked
at this and everybody's looked at it
said there's nothing there
ask the right question that's the right
question
I say bingo Peter Doocy because why oh
the abuse of power would be demanding
again why would a Vice President of the
United States of America be demanding
that some Ukrainian prosecutor be fired
or he's going to take a billion dollars
in your tax dollars home with him and
you got six hours to do it
Wow well Biden said there is not true
matter of fact that also that statement
of Peter Doocy is an outright lie here
are the facts in July he told The New
Yorker magazine that he has in fact
spoken with his son about his Ukrainian
business deals whoops hard time keeping
the story straight it's kind of hard to
keep up with lies sometimes now
ultimately this represents a clear
pattern of hypocrisy projection and the
Democratic Party and media the left
accuses President Trump of a quid pro
quo with Ukraine well it was actually
Vice President Biden issuing the billion
dollar quid pro
and the left spins in circles about a
mere allegation of a promise between the
president and the president of Ukraine
but barely yawns when President Obama is
saying I'll have more tell Vladimir on
more flexibility after the election
don't tell the American people just tell
them Vladimir you know the the hostile
actor that he is a lot more flexibility
don't tell the American people though
yeah we have that on tape for two-plus
years the left freaking out about Trump
Russia collusion didn't work out that
way did it but we actually have tape of
collusion with somebody who thinks he's
talking to a Russian that has dirt on
Donald Trump there is the cowardly ship
who's caught on tape trying to acquire a
compro mat on Trump for some Russian
pranksters and what is the nature of the
compliment pick the naked tadam naked
through the did flatted mirror see them
the Vladimir have them
yeah but the cause glad to me see
pictured naked Trump we got the tape and
she met with Trump and she brought him
one our Russian girl celebrity Olga boo
Sava who also known as a person with a
strange reputation Oh boobs ever what's
the nature of the compromise well there
were pictures of naked Trump and Putin
was made aware of the availability of
the compromising material yes of course
thank you very much we will be back in
touch with you through our staff to make
arrangements to obtain these materials
for our committee and and for the FBI
and I appreciate your reaching out to us
did they get that oh they don't exist
just like the dossier was full with lies
you know people hookers urinating in a
bed in the Ritz Moscow
yeah when the FBI finally got around to
verifying the dirty dossier that Hillary
paid for likely Russian disinformation
yeah from the beginning yeah and none of
it was true the left also accused the
Trump campaign of working with Russia to
spread misinformation Hillary's bought
and paid for dirty dossier was
proliferated in the media
well like people Oh conspiracy theorists
like Michael Isikoff and David corn
left-wing hacks that spew any propaganda
that's handy tool and also throughout
our federal government by the DNC
remember likely disinformation from the
get-go late in the game the New York
Times caught up with us finally
admitting that and according to a brand
new article from John Solomon Democrats
have a history of enlisting Ukraine in
American elections in 2016
DNC contractors they attempted to
persuade the country Ukraine to publicly
trash Trump's one-time campaign manager
Paul Manafort they also tried to get the
Ukrainian embassy in the u.s. to dig up
Russian dirt on then candidate Trump
Ukraine states that these efforts were
rebuffed because quote it recognized
they were in proper improper efforts to
get a foreign government to try and
influence the election against Trump and
for Hillary Clinton and Ukrainian
prosecutors even tried to hand over
evidence of the Democrats attempt to
engage in election interference with a
foreign country but were initially
turned away by the DOJ
I'd like to see those and by the way
while election interference and the mob
doesn't particularly care well of course
not
it's only when Trump does something
wrong no doubt Democrats will be set up
to their old tricks in 2020 after all
yeah joe 303 through t EO does have some
very close ties to ukraine unfortunately
for Biden if congressman Nunez is
correct the former vice president will
never cross the finish line as the
party's nominee by the way we haven't
even mentioned hunter Biden's trip with
his father to China that deal was 1.5
billion dollars